legendary actor Gene Wilder dead at 83  wanna change the world there's nothing  to the iconic comedian best known for  his roles in Willy Wonka and the  Chocolate Factory and Blazing Saddles  died from complications from Alzheimer's  disease genes nephew confirmed the news  to ET the celebrity tributes poured in  on Twitter following the news of genes  death  Rob Lowe called the actor one of his  earliest heroes Russell Crowe said he  watched Blazing Saddles seven times as a  kid writing gene you were a genius while  Harry Connick jr. tweeted so sad to  learn of the passing of my good friend  gene Wilder such an incredible man I'll  miss you and genes longtime collaborator  Mel Brooks shared this sentiment Gene  Wilder  one of the truly great talent of our  time he blessed every film he did with  his magic and he blessed me with his  friendship  you